Війна в Україні може зайти у глухий кут і є великий ризик того, що вона перейде у позиційну.
Про це йдеться у серії публікацій головнокомандувача Збройних сил України Валерія Залужного для видання The Economist.
Позиційний етап, на відміну від маневрового, призводить до довгих, виснажливих боїв.
Такий тип війни вигідний Росії і може стати пасткою для України.
Оскільки це дозволить противнику відновити свої військові ресурси,
а Україна залежить від постачання зброї Заходом.
Ми дійсно входимо в позиційну війну.
Ні російська зброя, ні українська, яка є в наявності, не дозволяє здійснити
істотного прогресу на полі бою, тому що технології подібні.
Відповідно, йде оцінка контрнаступу, який був проведений,
і фактично генерал Залужний визнає помилки, які були,
при тому, що не вдалося зайти в Крим за цей час, як планувалося, зрештою.
Ну, і констатація того, що ми не можемо дозволити собі  змагатися з Росією
в мобілізаційному потенціалі, тому що в Росії він більший.
Відтак, наша перемога і перевага українських військ
має полягати в організації правильних підходів до керівництва операціями,
командуванням, інноваційністю, креативністю і збільшенням
застосування сучасних технологій, які б давали можливість здійснити прорив на полі бою.
Це заклик, прохання: нам потрібна ваша підтримка,
нам потрібні ваші технології і нам потрібні кращі технології, щоб досягти прогресу.
Очікування західних лідерів були надто високими і літній контрнаступ показав,
що спроможності українських військ були переоцінені.
Кожного разу надходила нова зброя, наприклад, HIMARS.
О! Це буде тим, що змінить гру, і росіяни програють.
Потім інша зброя. І це супроводжувалось піаром у пресі.
Була надія, що щось зміниться. Але росіяни адаптувалися, тож ми зараз маємо цей глухий кут.
І Залужний визнав це.
За словами генерала Залужного, розрахунки щодо контрнаступу не виправдалися.
Технологічний рівень українських та російських військ загнав обидві сторони у ступор,
а у контрбатарейній війні Україна досягла паритету з РФ.
Він говорить, що за чотири місяці вони могли би пройти і південь,
тобто звільнити південь, Запорізьку і Херсонську область, і в тому числі провести операцію в Криму.
Як виявилося, що розрахунки виявилися невірними,
в тому числі генерал Залужний говорить про те, що він помилився в цих розрахунках
через те, що росіянам вдалося створити просто багато ешелоновану оборону
на кшталт Першої світової війни і за умов відсутності панування в повітрі, що змінило б ситуацію.
У нас технологічний паритет зараз з Росією.
Дуже цікава фраза його, що все, що робить Росія, ми бачимо,
і все, що ми робимо на полі бою, вони бачать.
Фактично висновок такий, що ці загальновійськові операції
з глибокими проривами великих груп військ вже в минулому,
оскільки масове використання дронів та інших засобів розвитку і радіоелектронної боротьби
фактично робить всі ці рухи відомими для противника,
а тому ці великі угруповання військ знищуються,
як, наприклад, це відбувається зараз в Авдіївці,
де Росія сконцентрувала величезні сили на маленькій ділянці фронту.
Начебто за такими загальними канонами ХХ століття вони мали би досягти успіху,
але через те, що українські війська мали, наприклад, технологічну перевагу
з точки зору використання ФПВ-дронів, засобів розвідки і абсолютно контролювали ситуацію,
це призвело до величезних втрат російських військ.
Але довго так тривати не може, оскільки позиційна війна призведе до економічних втрат
і до виснаження населення: як в Україні, так і за кордоном, вважає Олександр Мусієнко.
Це дає можливість накопичувати сили ворогові для, можливо, початку нових атак.
Це дає можливості і нам, звичайно.
Але тут залежить від того, яке буде забезпечення України
і чи не призведе це дійсно до втоми Заходу,
і чи ця позиційна війна, зрештою, не закінчиться тим,
що наші західні партнери будуть шукати шляхи,
яким чином можливо домовитися з Росією про припинення вогню, перемир'я тощо.
Це може призвести до окопної війни, розтягнути це в часі,
що, зрештою, може призвести до дійсно втоми Заходу
і, зрештою, до досягнення якихось домовленостей і політичних рішень,
які Україну можуть не влаштувати і навряд чи дуже будуть подобатися.
Головнокомандувач ЗСУ робить висновок, що для того, аби перемогти,
потрібен технологічний прорив, який складається із п’яти пунктів.
Для цього треба завоювати перевагу в повітрі,
подолати глибоко ешелоновану систему мінно-вибухових загороджень,
підвищити ефективність контрбатарейної боротьби,
створити й підготувати необхідні мобілізаційні резерви
і наростити спроможність радіоелектронної боротьби.
Нам потрібен технологічний прорив, який може відбутися
лише через комплексний підхід до всіх технологій,
які в нас є, які існують взагалі зараз передові розробки,
і все це має бути використано на полі бою,
починаючи від систем радіоелектронної боротьби,
які мають посадити російські безпілотники,
мають забезпечити вільну роботу наших безпілотників.
Це штучний інтелект, який можна використовувати для керування роїв безпілотників,
це автоматизовані системи управління, які мають бути всеосяжними, комплексними,
на всіх рівнях управління військ, які дають можливість в реальному масштабі часу
визначати цілі противника, передавати на командний пункт
і передавати на засоби ураження фактично в реальному масштабі часу,
без жодних затримок.
І саме це дає можливість говорити про подальші перемоги в цій війні.
Військові цілі обох сторін різні.
Україна хоче повернути собі території та звільнити людей.
Росія ж має великий інтерес у тому, щоб принаймні зберегти статус-кво.
Цього буде достатньо, і таким чином вона створює цю реальність.
Той, хто нападає, має застосувати більше сили, аби змінити статус-кво.
А це робить ситуацію для України важчою,
адже вона має докладати набагато більших зусиль, ніж Росія,
яка може ще більше укріплювати позиції, котрі зайняла,
і таким чином цементувати розділ України.
Так само, на думку генерала, важливо завдати ударів по території Росії
для знищення систем протиповітряної оборони,
об'єктів інфраструктури, командних пунктів, складів з боєприпасами.
І важлива така ремарка, яку він зробив, що навіть F-16,
які, наприклад, якби вони були рік тому,
вони б були набагато дієвішими, ніж якщо вони будуть через рік,
або через пів року з цього сьогоднішньої дати,
оскільки росіяни готуються до цього і почали розміщувати масово по кордону з Росією,
ну і на окупованих територіях, удосконалені системи С-400,
які мають велику дальність і можуть вражати в тому числі F-16 на полі бою,
а це створює великі загрози і для сучасних літаків.
Тому нам треба якраз виходити з того, що знищувати ці засоби ППО
на території противника для того, щоб забезпечити вільну роботу тих же F-16 над полем бою.
Зброї, наданої Україні Заходом, недостатньо для того,
щоб перемогти у війні, констатував Валерій Залужний.
А танки і ракетні комплекси великої дальності прийшли в Україну із запізненням.
Так річ у тім, що в Україну ще не надійшло навіть 100% допомоги, яка була обіцяна раніше.
Ну тобто це не те, що зараз ми просимо,
а це те, про що було домовлено раніше під час форматів Рамштайн,
під час перемовин, які відбувалися там за участю президента, за участю військових, Міноборони тощо.
Тобто навіть всі ці ще нам не поставили, не кажучи вже про те, що ми потребуємо додатково.
Це також стало причиною уповільнення контрнаступу на півдні.
Хоча, на думку експертів, не можна казати, що контрнаступ провалився чи зупинився.
Він продовжується і триватиме взимку.
Якщо погода буде морозною і сухою, на думку Михайла Самуся, активні бойові дії продовжаться.
Російські війська будуть намагатися атакувати на авдіївському напрямку,
українські війська на бахмутському,
а на півдні триватимуть бойові дії на лівобережжі Херсонської області і на запорізькому напрямку.
Іде намагання переграти противника якраз в маневруванні резервами.
Тому я би не говорив, що та операція провалилася, чи вона зупинилася. Вона продовжується.
Але, як пам'ятаєте, можливо, генерал Буданов сказав, що ми вибилися з графіку.
Росія домагається тривалої окопної війни.
Україна прагне цього уникнути, оскільки така війна може затягнутися і виснажити країну.
Росія не рахується з втратами, у той час, як для України людський ресурс дуже важливий.
Тому генштаб і керівництво країни шукають технологічні шляхи, щоб виграти цю війну.